e
e e
thank you welcome welcome to our
committee thank you uh to identify
myself I'm Michael moral I'm the
director of the administrative rules
office which is part of office of
legislative
services so a little guide to rulemaking
um especially regarding your um agen
excuse me your committee environment and
agriculture
um let's start broadly what is a rule
it's basically a
requirement um adopted by an agency
affecting people outside the rule
um it uh means each regulation standard
form um or other statement of General
applicability adopted by an agency to a
Implement interpret or make specific a
statute inforced or administered by such
agency or B prescribed or interpret an
agency policy procedure or practice
that's binding on purpose uh persons
outside the
agency uh there are 10 basic Ru making
principles U they come about mostly from
legal cases or directly from RSA 541a
which is the administrative procedures
act um rulle making is lawmaking with
legislative
oversight um rule making Authority comes
only from the legislature either in a
statute or session law and it's not
inherent with the
agency rules have the force and effect
of law if validly adopted and filed and
and if they have not expired and they
shall not be enforced
otherwise Ru making may not modify
statutory law that is the statutes
always Trump the rules Ru making by
agencies is governed by RSA 541a and
less
Exempted uh and agent agency is an
executive branch
entity a rule is a rule by what it does
uh even it's even if it's not called a
rule um the example that we give uh is a
legal case asmussen versus Commissioner
of Department of Safety which is over 20
years old um in that case the department
I think the commissioner was not happy
with the U rate of findings of guilt for
uh administrative license suspensions
people would have been stopped for that
they will come in for a hearing and
commissioner felt I assume it was a
commissioner um felt that there wasn't
high enough conviction rate so the a
memo was put out to all the hearings
officers and they have I don't know six
or eight hearings officers that hear
these cases um and it said the hearing
officers shall do certain things uh for
example it said if police officer cannot
make it to the hearing then the meeting
would be continued if the
uh defendant does not show up then
there'll be a finding against the
defendant well you know maybe that's
fine in principle but it wasn't the only
people that knew this were the hearings
examiners and requirements like that
obviously affected people outside the
department uh it someone sued it went to
the Supreme Court court and they said a
rule is a rule whether you've adopted it
or not and you can't uh implement it if
you have not adopted it through the
regular
process and by the way feel free to
interject anytime you want Mr moral
could you moral right Moral Moral I'm
sorry could you introduce yourself a
little bit about what office you're from
and what your background is before we
get into yep thank you I'm the director
of the uh administr administrative rules
office which is part of office of
legislative Services um I have been here
about 31 years first as a committee
attorney then Senior attorney and then
for the last two years as a
director um I have done both sides
because when I was a legal intern back
in 85 to 887 I uh worked for the
Department of Safety and helped do their
rules thank you
yep
um some of these uh basic rule making
principles came from an opinion of the
justices in
1981 uh the legislature adopted the
administrative procedures act RSA 541a
back in
1973 um but it really had no teeth so uh
the legislature inquired of the Supreme
Sue Court as to what they could do could
they have a committee of the legislature
that uh voted up or down on the rule and
the court said no because the
legislature as a whole had granted the
rul making authority to the department
to have a single committee say no we
don't like that rule uh we don't think
it uh conforms to legislative intent
then you basically have a pocket veto so
um so Jael car The Joint legislative
committee on administrative rules was
two years later uh created by
Statute it's a statutory sub uh
committee it's uh five regular me uh
five regular members from the house five
regular members from the Senate and five
alternates from each body um they are
not a policy committee they are an
oversight committee it can be difficult
some times for them to switch hats from
policy makers to oversight but they work
very hard at that and try not to
substitute their opinion for what the
legislature has put in statute their
power is limited in that um they can
object based on four reasons if they
object they can enter a well I should
stop and go through the process um when
an agency wants to do a rule it will
draft up the text um as you know with
the Department of envir Environmental
Services they often engage uh people
that will be affected prior to the rulem
or during that Ru making hearing when an
agency does a rule it's required by law
to have a public hearing the public
hearing is at least three weeks after
they've published notice in the
rulemaking register the register is
something that's put out by our office
every week every Thursday uh you should
be all getting a copy uh via
email there has now for over year been a
link in the register so that you can
actually look at the text of the rule
um after their agency submits their
notice we review it and before they
submit their notice they have to go to
the LBA and fill out a form for the LBA
saying what the costs and benefits of
the rule are uh
and the LBA then uses that information
to publish a fiscal impact statement
which the agency files with us as part
of its notice uh the rule making notice
form which explains the rule says when
the hearing is uh says when the written
comment deadline is and includes
includes the fiscal impact statement
um then they have their public hearing
which as I said is at least three weeks
later later um they usually put post
that on their own websites um but there
is no requirement to post at any place
but the rulemaking register which I
think personally is not the best way
because most of the public does not get
the uh ruem
register um they are also obliged to
notify anybody that has uh informed them
that they would like to be notified of
any Ru making in a given
area so then the agency has its public
hearing sometimes they have more than
one if it's a really hot topic uh
education has got a couple of rules
right now that there's a lot of public
interests and they had a couple of
hearings on one of them uh Dees
occasionally does that uh they can
either do do it twice during the formal
process or they can have a pre- Ru
making hearing um
they take that import and draft a final
proposal based on public comments and
based on comments from my office uh we
make comments on everything from grammar
all the way to constitutional issues uh
we look particularly at the four bases
for the that the that jel car can object
to um which are
Authority does he does the agency have
rulemaking
authority uh legislative intent which is
a big one um a lot of the comments we
make about legislative intent involve
conflicts with RSA 541a if they've
missed a step that they're supposed to
take under that statute we'll make a
comment if the rule is simply unclear
well there's a requirement in 541a that
it be clear um they're also required to
comply with the rulemaking manual which
is about 175 page manual that all
agencies have to for uh follow because
it's supposed to be uniform set of rules
so if you went from one agency to the
other you would know uh generally how to
find something and how it would be
written instead of having a over a
hundred different methods um it's sort
of like writing statutes they're all
fairly
uniform um committee can also object
based on public interest and you say
well how can they do that if they're not
a policy committee um they can do that
because in their own rules which is
attached to the rulemaking manual um
they are very limited in what they can
do for contrary to public interest if
the rule is unclear and people can't
understand what it says then it's
contrary to public interest if the rule
can't be uniform formally enforced then
that's contrary to public interest um
there are other couple smaller ones the
final basis for objection is um a
violation of fiscal impact statement in
other words a fiscal impact statement
says uh a B and C are the costs and D is
the benefit of the proposed rule well
they forgot to mention the fee they've
put in the rules um which obviously is
going to have an imp act but
particularly if it's a new
fee and after the final proposals
drafted and submitted to us we also re
review the final proposal we every time
they file with us we review at least
twice to make sure we haven't missed
anything we still do but we do the best
we can
um So based on our com comments in the
Public's they draft their final proposal
they submit it to us um they have up to
180 days to file the final proposal so
they can take quite a while to uh do it
that amount of time is really needed
because of some of the boards uh there
are boards in the state that only meet
once every three months so it's
difficult for them to go through the rul
making process in statutory time and
repres yeah I just wanted to because I
want
toite one second for question go
ahead thank you and I hope if this is
it's better to have this question
answered later let me know but I'm I'm
curious about learning more about
legislative intent and what that entails
because you're talking about an
executive department and an executive
department right is subject to the
political pressures of the executive but
I'm interested in how legislative intent
is ascertained right because you've got
the legislation that is on the books but
then you also have for example a a a
clear history in this case of this body
being on record for example with regard
to landfill sighting these are bills
that were vetoed for example by the
governor right so I I'm just curious
about like how specifically legislative
intent is discerned I was going to do
that after the general overview if
that's okay yes thank you very much okay
mine is just about this so time frame
wise I just want to if you can just
succinctly so we're looking at um the
the notice goes out yeah once they file
the notice with us clock starts um and
that notice was we were all just noticed
of that yes okay and they have and they
have to wait at least three weeks before
they can hold their public hearing yep
and then they have to wait at least
another five days uh generally speaking
U to accept written comment okay perfect
so notice clock starts 3 weeks of public
for the P to the public hearing notice
yep okay and
then um public hearing takes place
correct five days to
written generally that is technically
boards and commissions can uh do vote on
their final proposal at the end of the
public hearing process most because of
past experiences try not to do that
because it raises the question well how
much you taking into account the public
testimony if you've already got the
final proposal
drafted that has run into problems
before okay so yeah so I'm thinking so
public hearing to final proposal that's
the time frame so what are we looking at
there 180 days yeah it depends on the
agency most of them will file
within the final proposal within a month
or two of the public hearing sometimes
it'll be within 10 days of the public
hearing um it depends on how rushed they
are how long the rule is a rule could be
a sentence or it could be 100 Pages well
I was just going to say and in this case
there's it's very long my other question
is okay so and I have a bill in which
looks like it's going to pass which is
fantastic that changes this a little bit
um that gives
um public testimony uh the emphasis kind
of that it needs so for example
requiring which is kind of kind of what
we do here in the legislature but it
makes the agencies post their stuff onto
their website and any of the written um
that they could do that whether it's
emailed to them or scanned in which was
fantastic so um it's looks like it's
going through which is wonderful uh I
was just checking on it actually because
I think it's going to be an exec today
so that won't apply probably for stuff
that's going on right now but um so
after the public hearing the I do know
that the the comments on each let's say
substantial
thing we is that in that 180 days
because my bill changes this a little
bit so that's why I'm trying to
understand right now it's it's it's
really not defined y um it would yes
right now as of October 3rd of last year
yeah agencies are required to do
something that
uh uh Environmental Services has done
for years and oplc recently because one
of their attorneys was it ran the legal
unit at Dees for decades and that is
every public comment they get uh they
list what the comment is they uh say
what change they're going to make
because of the comment or if they're not
going to change it they specify why and
with Dees it could be a citizen it could
be a business owner it could be a EPA
and they go through all of that and then
separately they do the same thing with
the comments that my office
provides wonderful last question um so
the piece that is um right now that
we're trying that this new legislation
is going to help with a little bit is
time frame right so you have this
wonderful public hearing let's say
there's gobs of testimony real good
stuff right and um and people are kind
of like okay well what happens now
that's kind of like where there's been a
black hole
and and my bill is trying to be able to
get that up online to the point where
and the response that Dees is going to
do so people have enough time to kind of
see where that's at before it goes
directly sometimes it's only five days
before it's going into like JL car and
that's a huge issue so to be able to
have that you know kind of the public
testimony up and the responses back so
it's more transparent because you know
the you know the public is you know it's
it's hard sometimes after you you
testify at a hearing even here you know
on the on the house side and the Senate
side you're kind of like okay well where
did that go what's the process you know
trying to then having to try to chase
down when the next hearing is or
executive session it's I feel as if it's
it's difficult for um our constituents
and you know they're the boss and so I
really wanted that's why this bill was
put in so usually right now the last
time I looked at this it was about with
another agency um in the kind of the
response back it was only like about
five days so that's not something right
now that you guys can control correct
right um the new process that I just
summarized where they do a summary of
the comments they are required now to
file that with their final proposal so
you're not seeing the comments well in
advance
uh the final proposal once it's filed it
will go on to the next month's committee
meeting it has to be filed at least
three weeks before a jail car meeting in
order to be taken up that's another
chance for the public to see what's in
there uh because sometimes the changes
from an initial proposal to a final
proposal are uh significant sometimes
they're just minor
changes well that's a good thing so then
we'll be able to three weeks before the
first yellow JL car meeting um Meeting
those replies and stuff would be would
have to be live correct right perfect
and in fact in House Bill 1622 y I'm
from that period of three weeks will be
lengthened to four weeks wonderful
that's very good so basically a month
before they go before Jael car the
agency will have had to file final
Proposal with us that's that's wonderful
thank you so much yep
um okay the agency has filed the final
proposal as I said we review that twice
uh one of the committee attorneys we
have three committee attorneys two
administrative staff and
myself um the attorneys will go through
it and then I will take another look at
it to see if there's anything that was
missed those comments then go out to the
agency they are available to the public
um agency's required to if anybody makes
a request they're required to give them
copies of anything that's been filed
initial proposal rule making notice form
uh final
proposal uh so we com comment it and
then the final proposal goes to Jael car
um when it does go to jel car the agency
would be there the at jel car's meeting
and we would be there we're their
counsel by Statute um and we would raise
the more significant points to them
regarding the rule we don't bother with
the editorial stuff we might make a lot
of editorial things well you used a
period here and it was supposed to be a
semicolon uh You misspelled this word uh
but the committee doesn't want to deal
with that I mean technically those
things violate the manual and they could
object on but they're not of importance
enough to do that so the committee
listens to the agency and to us uh if
they're
satisfied in first the committee is not
required to make an objection there
could be something fairly black and
white but there are circumstances
outside uh that they decide not to
object say Dees needs to get a rule in
by a certain date or are they going to
lose Federal funding well if there's
anything really troubling with the rule
the committee would probably approve it
they might approve it with a
recommendation or understanding that the
agency will go back through rulemaking
to address those remaining
issues
um there's also another step after the
final proposal agency gets our final
proposal comments and they said oh yeah
those three things they brought up yeah
that that's not right we should correct
that they can then put in what's called
a conditional approval it's basically an
amend to the final proposal
um and maybe they got late filed public
testimony and they want to do it that
maybe they noticed a mistake of their
own or because of one our of our
comments if they file one the committee
will take up take that up with a final
proposal um they can conditionally
approve the rule which means the agency
goes back and submits the exact changes
they said that doesn't go back to jail
car unless they don't do it exactly as
Jael car said we we simply review it in
my office um if there's no conditional
approval the committee's going to look
at the find well either way they're
going to look at the final proposal and
decide whether to approve conditionally
approve or enter a preliminary objection
if they enter a preliminary objection
they're saying well we think these three
issues um have a problem we're going to
enter a preliminary objection the agency
then has 45 days to come back to Jael
car uh with a preliminary objection
response um in which they make changes
or if they don't wish to make changes
then in a cover letter they explain why
it's not appropriate to make those
changes
um and if the jail card enters a
preliminary objection the agency comes
back committee can approve the rule if
the committee is still not satisfied
that they've eliminated the basis for
objection they can make a final
objection but because the committee is
doesn't have veto power the agency still
can go ahead and approve the rule uh
adopt the rule over the committee's
final objection the final objection has
the effect that if commit if the agency
adopts it uh the rule over the object
final objection then if somebody sues
the agency regarding the rule the burden
of proof is going to to be on the agency
and if it gets a straight approval from
Jael card then there a presumption that
the rule is valid and the person would
have to go to court and prove that the
rules invalid but with final objection
the burden of proof
switches and one final step if
Committee in in addition to or instead
of the final objection they can vote to
sponsor a joint
resolution that's where they believe
there's a really serious issue and they
think it needs to be addressed by the
entire
legislature U there are time frames for
doing that uh if it's filed before the
session well I either way there's a
limited time for the legislature to deal
with that joint resolution they're
pretty rare they used to be common way
back when 25 years ago uh because after
28a part one article 28a of the
Constitution was adopted it said you
can't pass on cost to political
subdivisions if you're an
agency um and so the committee made
frequent objections with Dees about that
because they said well this is imposing
a cost on them but over the last two or
three decades the Supreme Court has
pretty much whittel down the effect of
uh 28a so it rarely comes up
anymore there was a decision called city
of conquered about 10 years ago that
it's ridiculous really uh took the guts
out of
28a yeah I perhaps I missed it but could
could you say something about the
conditional approval you said there's
approval there's conditional approval
and there's preliminary objections but
could you speak to what conditional
approval means okay uh you've submitted
the final
proposal we have reviewed it uh made
comments and the agency said yeah we
need to fix this so they ask for a
conditional approval they basically
bring up another copy of the text
showing further changes uh to correct
the problem uh maybe Jael car said well
you don't have author Authority for this
paragraph So the agency might agree and
decide to take out that paragraph and
the committee would look at the
conditional approval and say yes or no
um and that that's basically that
process the additional approval is filed
with our office we review that just like
we do the final proposal and tell the
committee whether we think the process
and whether the problems have been
eliminated and and at that point then it
becomes approved once the conditions are
met then it's approved the conditional
approval Goes to Jail car and jail car
can say yeah this cleaned up the issues
that were raised back the jail car for
round two to sort out the condition yeah
it goes there with the final proposal
and the agent the committee can say well
between the final proposal and the
further changes you made in the
conditional approval then we think the
rule is okay but they can decide that
the uh conditional approval doesn't do
enough to eliminate the issues so
they'll do a preliminary objection based
on the final proposal okay thank
you
uh and most most of the rules agencies
adopt are what we call regular rules
those are valid for 10 years uh agencies
a lot of the rules we get are not
implementing new legislation or setting
a new policy they're reopt an already
existing Rule and if say if the rule is
eight years old and their statute has
changed or they really realize they need
to change the process then as part of
reopt that rule they will also amend it
U that's majority of
ruem um there can be because of in the
ruem register if you look at the list of
new uh notices that have come in the in
the uh prior week if you see an asterisk
then the purp then that rule is
implementing new legislation basically
from the last one or two
sessions and that means that the
subcommittees that have been set up uh
to review rules uh can take a look at
that and say
yeah we think there's a legislative
intent uh problem here we're going to
tell the agency we're going to tell jail
car um if the agency doesn't deal with
it then subcommittee could be come
before Jael car and state their
concerns legislative intent can be
really hard to nail down um some
statutes of Grant rule making Authority
are very specific and it's easy to tell
some of them have to be specific 541a
says if you're going to do a new form of
license a new form of fee a new
discipline um then you have to have
specific Authority in your statute it
has to say you shall develop uh this new
disciplinary measure uh if it doesn't
they cannot do that uh but otherwise
legislative intent can be difficult
because it might not be specific I know
some of the boards and commissions have
rulemaking authority it says any rule
necessary to implement this chapter well
that leaves it pretty broad wide open
for the agency to adopt rules and in
that instance it can be very hard for
the committee attorneys to say whether
something is within legislative intent
or
not that can also be difficult for jail
cart to determine uh if we can't see
with legislative intent because first
thing you do is look at the wording of a
statute I mean if it's clear on its face
then that's what's implemented that's
legislative intent um if we can't tell
whether the a thing the agency wants to
adopt in their rules Falls within that
intent we'll try to look up uh the
legislation see what was said in
committee hearings see what was said on
the floor um might even involve uh
research office within OS to help us on
that uh and the agency is free you know
if we do raise a a legislative intent
issue the agency will come to jail cart
and explain why they believe they do
have
authority and agencies are pretty good
about uh legislative intent uh there are
places where they're not absolutely sure
and they think what they're putting in
the rule is necessary to carry out the
program uh Jael car might disagree there
are times when say a commissioner really
wants something and maybe he's trying to
put a square peg in a round hole and uh
then the committee has to decide on
that
questions thank you Mr chair thank you
very much for coming to talk to us today
and and so this has more to do with
legislative intent and this is one of
those kind of I know strict
constructionist kind of questions in the
sense of
when we talk about legislative intent or
we talking about the intent of the
legislature that passed the law the RSA
or are we talking about the current
legislature the courts have said you
know it's the intent of the entire
legislature when they voted well frankly
that's hard to discern sometimes uh with
as many bills you have to deal with at
one time on the floor
um the intent of the sponsor might be
looked at but that's not uh controlling
neither is the uh intent of the
committee that you know uh did the blur
before the house or Senate um those
might be factored in
but so it can be hard to nail down what
legislative intent is I follow up yes
please U thank you and because what I'm
wondering is as I said I understand it's
it's difficult right because these
agencies are executive agencies ahead of
the agencies are appointed by the
governor right um and but RSA is made by
primarily by the legislature yeah um and
and so executive departments are in the
situation where they're between those
two Powers right the executive power and
the legislative power and my concern is
what happens when when rules go forward
that the legislature feels do not
reflect
feedback that it has consistently given
to the agency so if you've had several
bills for example that have in some
cases gone all the way through been
vetoed to me that's an expression of the
will of the legislature you've had an
oversight committee that has provided
feedback um and my concern is what
happens if the legislature feels that
its feedback has simply not been
incorporated into the rules process okay
uh smaller part of that first if the
legislature vetos a bill and then the
agency tries to implement that there's a
strict prohibition on it they cannot do
that no the
governor I understood what you me yeah
so that that so it is one of that it's
it's trying to discern if if I'm getting
this correctly the
intent of the legislature at the time
that it passed the RSA that is being
interpreted right uh just for an example
I can remember long ago because the
department of safety has um Marine
Patrol uh the upper echelon in the
department decided we should have an
auxiliary uh Marine Patrol well there
was nothing about it in the statute and
so there was a big argument in front of
jel car as to whether that conformed
with the legislative
intent thank you repres
Penza okay
so to understand because I'm going to go
back off of legis islative
intent in a perfect world how it's
supposed to work is there's current RSA
there's a cur there's you know recent a
recent bill that was passed whether it
be a year or two ago let's say there's
rule making that um you know is is
coming up you know Ru making is not
necessarily happening you know every six
months or every year or something like
that okay so um so we're looking at okay
here's rule making is coming so we're
going to go based upon previous RSA that
you know or bills that were passed that
became law you know within the last
couple years or something like that now
when that that when none of that exists
at all we're going to have to I assume
look back to Old RSA pulling pieces from
other things because in a sense in in a
situation that we're in right now they
are kind of going in a sense going rogue
they don't have anything to basee their
rulemaking on legislatively
lawwills as he said you know that have
gone through have been
vetoed um so or maybe killed on the
other body or whatever it may be and so
I mean I'm a new rep so this is you know
um I only can talk from 23 to 24 but
some of this stuff has been going on for
five or six years now and you know even
longer in in certain things so to be
able
to whatever they're basing their their
rules on it should be based upon RSA and
through I mean committee hearings and
testimony and all of these types of
things that where we thought things were
headed are not so our only Power is
really to go dig through I assume old
RSA
right to say okay this doesn't match up
with this that's really that that's
really what we should be focusing on if
we have a real problem with certain
aspects of rules and that can be
difficult when a bill passed 20 or 40
years ago what was the intent of the
legislature on that rule that's why
there's a limit on this new process uh
that involves statutory uh subcommittees
of the standing committees uh to recent
legislation in other words a year or two
out because there are going to be
members on that committee that are aware
of that legislation when we're around
then but it doesn't always the rul
making doesn't always happen immediately
you know we sometimes get rules that are
implementing statutes that were three or
four years
old so
from this committee's perspective I gave
you a little bit of an outline
uh the last four months we've been
working with Dees to review the ru
making process right um the ru making
process has
gone um you know they've made a lot of
changes to the the rules with which
enhance environmental and public um
safety but they they have not made some
changes that people on this subcommittee
and in our committee believe are are
prudent and so we as the subcommittee
and the larger Committee of the
legislature what is our our recourse
then if we still believe at the end of
the
day the rules that they have are not as
stringent as they should
be um from what you just talked about it
would seem to me that um we can
interject in that 180 days we get or and
and in the time leading up to the public
hearing okay yeah go ahead um when the
notice is filed uh with the initial
proposal in it uh anything that was
initial proposal that was filed after
October 3rd of last year is going to
have that summary of public comments and
how they reacted to it so you'll be able
to see that if in reading the rule you
see something I don't think that can
forms to what the statute says then uh
you can certainly tell the agency and
they can take that into account when
they draft their final proposal if the
final proposal comes up and you still
have concerns you can again tell the
agency if they don't do anything further
like conditional approval you can come
to Jael car and explain your reasoning
and jail car May object on that uh the
other option basically is is new
legislation to say do this or don't do
that okay question representative
Haskins thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question
so somewhat of the
urgency we are experiencing is because
it's a 10-year update of the rules yep
so uh things
change new information comes about right
um um speaking for myself new legislator
that I
am I don't see that the public in input
is necessarily making its way into the
rules and since I represent the
public I would love some assurance that
the public comment
testimony is making it into the rules y
um I think that summary helps a lot so
you can see clearly whether something
did or not uh I'll be frank sometimes
public testimon want something that the
agency doesn't have the authority to do
um a new state a small state agency was
created recently the office of the UN
budsman for RSA 91a the right to no law
uh so people instead of going to court
if they're unhappy with the
decision say your local you asked for
information from your town they refuse
to give it you can go to the UN budsman
instead of going to court
um I know there was a lot of public
testimony when that agency was created
and on their rules and I saw some of it
and people were saying well you should
be able to do this to the governor uh
it's such you should be able to do this
which is blatantly
unconstitutional so some public
testimony does need to be rejected but
your point is very well
taken and for a fall thank
you I respect that but we aren't just
the public we are the legislators we are
supposed to write the laws and as this
subcommittee is formed to oversee the
rul
making I am not fully sure that our
comments have made it into the rules as
well
okay right it it should be easier to be
able to discern now well at least if you
went and testified at the public hearing
I mean if uh you just if a
Dees representative came before your
subcommittee and you told them of issues
that you thought were there and they
don't address it
then uh there are certainly political
ramifications that can be made but uh
you you won't know until you read the
rule whether or not they made those
changes or why they didn't make the
changes if I may just one last
please and the public hearing that's
coming up on the 20th in regard to the
800 rule um has been scheduled from one
to 4:00 in the
afternoon in talking with my colleagues
we don't feel like we should take the
Public's time to
testify because frankly it was scheduled
with inefficient in insufficient time
for the number of people who want to
speak so that's just one occasion where
I don't feel like we're getting through
yeah there is a statutory provision that
says if there's not enough time at the
hearing for for everyone to be heard the
agency can continue the he um hearing
they file a form with our office
specifies when the additional meeting is
going to be held uh likewise you know if
the weather is atrocious and they can't
get the meeting or get a quorum Etc they
can be continued uh if they realize
there going to be 100 people showing up
and they just were using a boardroom
then they can also change the
venue thank
youza so yeah just following up on what
you just said um there's been some folks
that have already uh reached out to I
have as well to Dees concerning that
just to say that because we know that
you know it's not going to be sufficient
um should we you know in a sense you
know whether it be our subcommittee or
our committee um you know maybe have a
combined letter to Dees to say hey you
should really extend this time or
whatever um What would I'm just asking
your opinion or should we wait I mean or
we could do both they might not respond
who knows um or change it or should we
wait until if there is a lot of people
there and feedback that we wait for it
to be you know extended what would your
what would your advice be to us about
that personally I think I would
recommend both because if you do the
letter and they don't respond and then
there are 10 or 15 people that don't get
H at the public hearing then the uh jel
car is going to take that much more
seriously because they had been informed
that that might be a problem let's do
that yeah perfect thank you so much for
that that's
great yes sir thank you representative
Jama so and I'm thinking about you know
how we might want to change the these
processes going down the road as my
colleague has some legislation in good
legislation to do that so under the
current kind of the way things currently
work so the the the legislature can pass
legislation have it vetoed by the
governor and then when it comes to the
rule writing process we can provide
input to an agency and the agency's
response to us can be well we listened
to you but we didn't incorporate
anything that you told us yeah um and in
the end the legislature ends up
essentially powerless correct because we
tried to change the
law we're required effectively in this
situation to a super majority to pass
any law because it has to be veto proof
so we tried to change the law we
couldn't and then we give feedback to an
agency and the agency says
effectively thanks but no thanks y
um so my qu do I have that right I mean
it it feels like the legislature is
pretty powerless uh when it comes to
actually affecting the rule writing
process in a substantive way that's true
but uh my experience has been that
uh agencies executive agencies ignore
the legislature to their own
Peril I hope that's I hope that's thank
you very much I appreciate that I like
that we're gonna quote that no I'm just
kidding and there is a requirement uh
that the agency give uh due
consideration to public comment they are
not required to make changes because of
that
comment they should any other questions
I
like hey thank you so much for your
preparation and your detail and your
cander would we very helpful okay
certainly uh and if you have any
questions uh give me a
call great thank you so much we and we
may okay in in the couple weeks okay
thank you thanks I appreciate
it particularly if you have any question
questions about the uh this particular
rule that's going to come
up absolutely
I've thank
you uh meeting is uh now adjourned thank
you Mr moral appreciate your attendance
thank you thank
you for